you gotta be smart when you're reaching
out to people you gotta
build to build a relationship beyond a
transaction
the only limits to your success are your
own imagination
when you're filling a gap that is so
needed then you find the commerce of
that business starts to make
absolute sense wanna be happy build a
life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside
youtube you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn from some of the
best
black female entrepreneurs on the planet
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one have relentless determination with
oprah winfrey
my television career began unexpectedly
as you heard this morning i was in the
miss fire prevention contest
that was when i was 16 years old in
nashville tennessee
and you had the requirement of having to
have red hair
in order to win up until the year that i
entered
so they were doing the question and
answer period because i knew i wasn't
going to win in the swimsuit competition
so during the question and answer period
the question
came why young lady what would you like
to be when you grow up
and by the time they got to me all the
good answers were gone
so i had seen barbara walters on the
today show that morning so i answered
i would like to be a journalist i would
like to
tell other people's stories in a way
that makes a difference
in their lives and the world and as
those words were coming out of my mouth
i went
whoa this is pretty good
i would like to be a journalist i want
to make a difference
well i was on television by the time i
was 19 years old
and in 1986 i launched my own television
show
with a relentless determination to
succeed at first
i was nervous about the competition and
then i became my own competition
raising the bar every year pushing
pushing pushing myself
as hard as i knew sound familiar to
anybody here
eventually we did make it to the top and
we stayed there for
25 years
the oprah winfrey show was number one in
our time slot for 21 years and i have to
tell you i became
pretty comfortable with that level of
success
rule number two find a champion with
michelle thornton g
you gotta find an advocate or a champion
matter of fact
don't leave this room until you have one
i didn't say mentor
great you can have a mentor that's
typical that's great that's amazing it
takes a long time to build a
relationship
but sometimes all you need is someone to
send an email on your behalf
we make it complicated right because if
i email on your behalf you're gonna get
a meeting
and it took me three minutes now this is
the rule when i leave here today please
don't let me see in my linkedin account
everybody's resumes and business cards
and pictures
and you know my auntie send me something
that i can use
be memorable do some research on me
this is not a game this is easy
you gotta be smart when you're reaching
out to people you gotta
build to build a relationship beyond a
transaction
because transaction means we're done
after we say hello
i'm giving you guys some tricks that i
have used to build relationships with
people
that are still meaningful today i can
absolutely tell you that i'm an evp
in the world's largest talent agency
where you don't see many people like me
look okay i'm kind of cute for 53 but
you don't still see a lot of people like
me
but my girl bozeman saint john made a
call from me and said
we should hire her and that's what went
down
but because we had a relationship
because we shared information because
i'm sending her stuff that she needs
because i see she's traveling so i sent
her a care kit
on the road okay i know she has a lot of
hair i sent her a bonnet
whatever it is be smart use your thing
get out of your phone
just to follow other people that don't
care about you
use the tool to get ahead there's a lot
of competition out there
rule number three be creative with
rihanna
it's really important for me to
expand to build to evolve to do things
bigger better try new
aspects of creativity very important for
me i get bored really quickly
so if i've done it i'm already bored of
it while i'm doing it
that's something i don't know if it's a
good thing or a bad thing
but i'm always like what's next what's
next i want something better i want
something different
how do we it doesn't necessarily have to
be
bigger but maybe it's deeper maybe we
just go deeper
and explore things that aren't being
discussed
rule number four solve a problem with
iman
it was in 1975 it was my first
photo shoot and it was for american
vogue and i have never worn heels
i've never worn makeup before i arrived
in the united states
uh i was uh you know studying political
science i've never seen fashion
magazines i had no idea that there was
anything called fashion that existed uh
you know in the world so at that
photoshoot i walked in
uh and there was another model on the
shoot and she was caucasian and the
makeup
artist asked me and i was by the way i
was then 19 years old
he asked me specifically did you bring
your own foundation
but it wasn't lost on me that he didn't
ask that question to the caucasian girl
so i thought something because i had no
idea what he was talking about i didn't
even know what foundation was
so then he proceeded to mix and match
some products and put it on my face
and uh and i looked in the mirror and i
looked gray i s
i looked horribly gray in my skin and so
what saved my career because that was my
first shoot
what saved my career was that the
photographs were actually black and
white
and those uh black and whites hide
multitude of sins
interesting uh you know but what i did
was that i made it my
my job to find something that was
suitable for my skin
so i went to all the department stores i
went to woolworth
you're too young to remember oh no of
course i rocked it at world wars 2.
i came out of the womb 10 with a martini
in 1975. so i was new i love you
i love you for that i love you for that
i did
so and i mixed that mixed product and
put it on my face
and i took a a polaroid camera and i
took pictures so i could see how will it
translate
that was the seed that was imp implanted
in my head that i have to take control
of my own image
you know we were talking about we were
talking about language but in
fashion and beauty you know our our
our our power is how we look our
currency
is how our images look so i wanted to
make sure that i took control of that
and that i could
put myself at the best forward life
without
you know and i never went to a fashion
shoot without a foundation from then on
and
then when i reached out i retired in
1989
and i created in 1994 iman cosmetics
for women with skin of color and i say
skin of color because before
i started my makeup everybody black
especially black were called just women
of color
and even now when you think about women
of color you only think about black
women
but i wanted a new language of beauty of
how to include
everybody in that is because there are
filipinos who are as dark as i
am there are puerto ricans who are you
know the same kind of brazilians who are
like so the whole world
i was not interested in the ethnicity i
was interested
in the spectrum of colors that the whole
world comes in rule number five
imagine with shonda rhimes my father has
always said to me the only limits to
your success
are your own imagination and growing up
i was
chubby in all the wrong places with coke
bottle thick glasses and two cornrow
braids down the sides of my head and i
was the youngest of six kids
but i had all of these dreams and ideas
of what i would be i had a lot of dreams
and a lot of ideas
i had fancies i had doodles in the brain
i had and still have an extraordinary
imagination
there were worlds inside their nations
and lands shondalands
the only limit to my success was my own
imagination
my father's saying that was a gift
because i really believed growing up i
could be whatever i imagined
and it's only now as a parent do i look
back to see how hard my parents must
have worked to make that belief possible
for me in the 1970s
the civil rights act wasn't even a
decade old when i was born
i mean my mom was like some sort of
superhero gladiator advanced team for my
life
single-handedly removing the
soul-crushing boulders of sexism and
racism from my path
paving the way so that by the time i
skipped happily along with my big ideas
and piles of writing
the road was smooth and easy they tell
stories of my mother in my hometown she
is legend
but i was blissfully unaware the only
limit to your success is your own
imagination
but still you have to be able to imagine
it
one day i turned on the tv and saw
something it had never occurred to me to
imagine
i saw this woman on tv and she was smart
and funny and emotionally honest and she
seemed unapologetically herself
she was in charge comfortable powerful
smart real
it was her show and she looked like me
she was a black woman on television and
then she was a black woman taking over
the world
through television she was oprah
oprah winfrey changed
oprah winfrey changed my imagination she
changed what i found to be imaginable
any limits to my success suddenly seemed
something clicked
and my imagination had no limits the
world got wider
and it wasn't overnight and it wasn't
just oprah but oprah was my first and
most powerful example on tv of someone
who looked like me
there was also claire huxtable in prime
time and will be goldberg live on
broadway
but i want you to hear me when i say
this because i'm betting some of you
have an image in your mind of what a
black childhood looked like so this
feels
typical to you but i was a middle class
kid
from the suburbs with a private school
education and nerdy intellectuals for
parents
i grew up sheltered from the ugliness of
any realities having to do with poverty
and real racism i play the oboe i was a
brownie
and i'd still never seen anyone on tv
who looked like me on the outside and
looked like me on the inside
it had never occurred to me that
television could be where my imagination
would be most at home
if you can't even imagine something how
can you reach for it
you cannot see what you cannot be and it
wasn't that i wanted to be
oprah but it was that i now knew there
was a door somewhere inside that
television screen
and that it was absolutely possible to
either knock on it or kick it down to
get inside
i knew that that world this world could
include me
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief the sign
says it can take up to 254 days of
consecutive action
for the habit of stick that's what i
want for you so i've designed a custom
free program we're going to send you an
unlisted video for the next 254 days
to shift your confidence and belief
forward
the link to join is in the description
below figure out
where your power base is so it's not
selfish to put yourself first no it's
self-full
it's self-full it's self-full to be
first to be as good as possible to you
to take care of you
so many times i get the question how do
i prevent
failure and i'd love for you to spend
that same energy going
how could i ensure that i soar
rule number six be aware of your money
blueprint with lisa nichols
i have this program where i look at your
money blueprint and i help you look at
your money blueprint
and and i ask you questions how is money
in your household
that was it uh the source of argument
the source of
contention and divisiveness because if
so
you don't want money to divide you and
your family so you might not want to
have money around or you want
too much because you don't want to be
divided you don't want to be judged
right whatever or did it keep your
parents away
like what was the what was your
relationship to money as a child
because that's fueling you that has an
unconscious
um influence over your filter of how you
see everything
exactly you want to bring from the
unconscious to the conscious you might
not be listening to it but you
definitely don't want it to have any
unconscious power over you so that's
number one
be aware of your money blueprint how is
money related to in your community
how is it related to in your house um
what what did you think about money
how's your faith attached to it
i used to think that literally in order
to be like sister brown who was like the
most godly woman in my church when i was
a teenager she was amazing but we also
have fundraisers for sister brown
um that i could not have a million
dollars in my bank account
and be sister brown yeah so i had to re
it took me years to do that
rule number seven nurture your vision
with the yonla vanzant
the spiritual code of conduct says
don't move till you have a vision
that's why we fail sometimes
you see a vision means that you can see
it on the inside
before you can experience it on the
outside
now you can have all the plans you want
but if you
can't see it nothing's going to happen
you got to have a vision and that comes
from you taking time to sit down and do
your daily spiritual practice
okay vision ain't gonna fall to you out
the top of the closet
you gotta do the work you gotta
sit down shut up
listen you gotta tune in
to your own channel not just youtube
facebook twitter snap the part or the
chat or whoever the hell the thing is
people be chat snapping i mean
do you snapchat okay you
and never reflecting
never uh uh correcting
so that they can be directed
correct reflect in order to be
directed rule number eight be different
with tabitha karanja
who are you targeting at the time with
the wine you were making
we were targeting the lower market
because we because we
felt they are the ones who are neglected
then they didn't have a drink that they
could put on the table
and drink they were left whatever was
available in their villages
right and we thought it was unhygienic
why don't you come up with a
product that is produced hygienically
and then affordable
and that means international standard
and then when we were doing that we also
discovered them in the middle
and the upper market and those didn't
also have choices
right and also we thought why don't you
come back again with a choice
and that's how we thought of coming up
with the summit lager and the summit lag
again we had to try and come up also
with a more superior product than what
was in the market
because you have to be different when
you come in don't just come and
copy the your competitor has been there
for many years
for people to turn uh nice or new
you have to make sure that you're
different so we came up with a more
superior beer
people didn't know that you can have a
beer and go and wake up in the morning
with no hangover
people didn't know that they can grab a
beer and have no aftertaste
yeah and they can also have a beer that
is also healthy with no
additives no sugar added and all that
and after we launched the summit lager
you can see it only took us very short
time to notice that
whatever we had launched was not enough
and that's why now we did this expansion
that you can see here
which you launched this year rule number
nine don't accept
no with foloronso al-lakhijah and i
went to see the patriar minister and
what they wanted
uh was to lift crude and the petroleum
minister said listen
the current administration at that time
really wanted to
move away from that preferred
to uh get nigerians to be more involved
in that
rather than you know giving that out to
to foreigners
so he said if they want to invest
in nigeria rather than come and lift
nigeria's crude then
they'd be willing to do that i took it
back to my friend
she took it back to the clients and her
clients said no we don't want to invest
in nigeria
we only wanted to lift
so we parted ways say bye-bye
and i said to myself now that i have an
enroll to
that place why don't i go and find
something i can do
all i wanted was a contract you
understand what i'm saying to
to boost uh you know my pocket
i still wanted to carry on doing my
fashion i love it yeah
so i went back
i asked mr bangida to please help me to
book another appointment
and i went to see the minister and i
told him that i was interested in
you know finding something to do with
the uh with oil industry where they
you know with an npc and i was given all
sorts of different options
that are possibilities you know
understand me
uh catering for those
on you know on the offshore yes and
maybe transporting crude from one
location to another
stuff like that so
i would sit down write my letter and
take it there out sometimes i had to
wait six months to get the appointment
yes wow sometimes four months and i
would
go back and he would punch holes
in what i had come to offer
and i would go back dejected
and i'll go and do some more homework
and then i'd get mr babangida to book
another appointment for me wow
so um that went on
they were all no no's which is one of
the reasons why i've made it one of my
mantras
never accept a no for an answer
so i came back home and i cried my eyes
out
my husband comforted me
and i called mrs babangida and i said
this is what i came back with
and she she said well
all she knows is that that kind of thing
takes years and we left it at that
and i carried on licking my wounds
and then i woke up one day and i said no
i'm not accepting that no
i'm not gonna allow that to just
twitter away yes it was like a wake-up
call
if you're not sure what's the matter
with you i thought you liked challenges
i was saying that to myself come on
do something about this what's there to
lose
yeah so i decided that
i was going to go back so i called mrs
banker and i said
please i'd like to ask you to please
book me one more appointment
and she did she was very kind she was
very wow
okay but that was all that she did
concerning this oil license wow
mata she kept on getting giving getting
me those appointments
and the rest was
what god wanted to do what he wanted to
do at first
by giving me that opening through my
friend because i would have never looked
at the oil industry correct so
i went back and i said to the
minister that i wanted to see whether i
could do this that i
really wanted want to apply for it
so he said okay you're going to do your
homework
um because it's nigerians that the
government of the day
wants to encourage now yeah
we have a lot of multinationals over the
years
we want to encourage nigerians we want
our resources and our wealth to be
retained
in our own uh land rather than having it
cutted away by foreigners all the time
so i applied
for the license three times
and that took three years three
years the ministers changed hands
twice and it was during the time of the
last one
that i eventually got it i think i was
one of the
first women to get the license
and it's very painful
when you listen to what
people say that oh it's because she made
blouses
for mrs babangida oh it's because she
she was one of them but how about all
the others
who got the license
and who weren't in the oil industry
at the time that they that they got the
license so because they're men
they have two words is it fair on
womanhood
why relegate us to the background why
say we can't
when we can when all the prerequisites
the boxes could be ticked i
made all of them available at technical
partners
and i i went here and there i did
everything i supplied everything i did
my homework
i learnt on the job
i went for courses as well to help me to
build me up
you understand to be able to sit in
boardrooms
and face others rule number 10 give
a personal touch with sheila johnson i
think from the very beginning when i
had the vision to build the salamander
resort
really based it on how i live from day
to day
and where i live i have an extraordinary
house that i completely renovated and
designed myself
and the design of the resort is very
similar
to my personal home and when i have
people come to this resort i want them
to feel a part
of my world i want them to be able to
step through those front doors and feel
like
i've come home again i want them to
experience something that is so
different
and when they walk around that resort
they're going to see
my personal touches from my photographs
to some linens that i've designed
items in in the gift shop that i
personally have designed
they're going to feel my presence
whether i'm there or not
it is my thumbprint that i am trying
to give as a gift to the world rule
number eleven
keep eye contact with janice bryant
howard
it's what would be difficult to
curate three big learnings
from such a short period of employment
because that employment period was truly
transformational in my life
i'll share with you what comes to mind
first okay
i remember distinctly tommy teaching me
always stand up when someone enters but
always make sure that you're at the same
eye level with them
during a conversation when he first
taught me that my mom had taught me to
stand when entering or when someone
enters your presence
but what tommy did was he he he
dynamically
would ensure that he was always eye
level with who
whoever he was speaking whether he was
across the desk in a passing or in a
meeting
and i thought when he first told me that
it was about his male ego you know
who's in charge just yesterday
i was playing for one of my business
brand groups a check
a video on and it's called the nurse
with the purple hair
and one of the things she says as she
conducts her work
in hospices is that she always keeps
eye level with the patient and so if
she's
changing an iv or administering
insulin through one she always will make
sure she and that patient are eye level
even if it means
kneeling on the floor to do so and she
said she does
that because it brings a level of
confidence
comfort and engagement that we're in
this together
so whether it's from tommy's position of
never letting anyone stand above you
or her position of never placing
yourself above someone else
i really have learned that lesson that
keeping eye level contact is important
to people
and it's it's dramatically important
if you're speaking from across cultures
or languages
and rule number 12 the last one before
some very special bonus clips
is tell your story with mo abudu
my first question is about your life as
a businesswoman and your company
ebonylife tv
so it's been extraordinarily successful
it's been the highest
ranked tea talk show for nine years in
africa it's aired no fewer than 49
countries in africa
i'm wondering what are the challenges
that face your company and indeed other
networks
that need to compete in a world in which
the opinions of our generation
are increasingly being formed online and
on social media
rather than on television thank you
it's great to be here by the way thank
you all so much for inviting me to share
this afternoon with you
um for me i believe that
deep down in my subconsciousness has
always been the need
to tell the african story so it's a
commercial venture
but it's also a social venture for me so
for me i don't see the divide between
work
and play so my staff get emails from me
at three o'clock in the morning and
think i'm absolutely crazy
but you know so so the journey started
for me
officially i would say about 10 years
ago
but i'll say that it's been a much much
longer journey than that
now i was born in england i was born at
a place called hammersmith hospital
went back to nigeria at age seven came
back to the uk at age eleven
but between age zero and seven and
eleven to whenever it was that i spent
the rest of my life here before i went
back as a married woman
you find that you do get asked really
interesting questions
by non-africans you know they will ask
you
um if you live in a hut um they will ask
you
if you live under a bridge they will ask
you if you speak
african but there is no such language as
african
africa is a continent with millions of
different languages
and i found that my children years and
years later
came back to the united kingdom um you
know to school
my son went to harold my daughter went
to marvin and they were being asked
similar questions 20 or 30 years later
and therefore i felt it was time it was
i was really
afraid because i was working in
exxonmobil as head of human resources
to say that it was time to take the
plunge and
put aside administrative work and really
start to tell this
journey you know start this journey of
telling the african story
i have no media experience up until that
point i'd never been trained in media
um so the first thing i did was to
obviously go on a training course and
learn how to speak
um hello and good morning or good
afternoon welcome to moments with mo and
whatever
you know it is that you one has to say
um so
so for me the journey started pretty
much from those
sort of baby steps to getting out there
and and sharing the story so
yes it it did become a commercial
venture because i think sometimes when
you're filling a gap
that is so needed then you find the
commerce
of that business starts to make absolute
sense to what it is that you're doing
i was able to go out and speak to
advertisers and speak to sponsors
and convince them that there was a need
for us to start sharing our stories
successful stories sometimes stories
that were not necessarily about some of
the great things happening
but women it could be an issue of
domestic violence of a woman that's
overcome the violence
it could be fashion it could be music it
could be great things
also so the reason for our being was
really to start showcasing some of the
great things that were happening across
the continent
and to shed light and balance on some of
those other issues
that was getting absolutely no air time
at all so in that regard it started to
make commercial sense
to me as an entrepreneur and were able
to take advantage of that
and build upon that success year after
year
um you know momentum has probably
recorded over two or three
you know over 800 um you know episodes
in that time
in that time period now i've got a
really special bonus clip that i think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the sign says that when you just
watch a video
you get motivated to get inspired you
have a 35 chance of following
through on your goals 35 that's not
enough that's not enough just to get
motivated believe nation we're here
you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through
when you write it down you have a 91
chance of following through
and when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 percent chance from
30 something percent to 95
chance of you following through believe
nation we need to make this happen
so question of the day your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action specific for the
next week
put it down in the comments below and
i'm going to show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you my
name is insula i'm the winemaker and
owner of aslina wines
originally from wasulu natal from the
village
which is the most beautiful space you
can ever be in because if you compare
the village
and the the cities the peacefulness you
get in the village is just amazing
and that's where i come from getting
into the industry it was one of those
things that it wasn't
a plan according to it by chance it was
an opportunity that actually presented
itself
and not that i didn't even know anything
about wine but it was like there's an
opportunity
and i was like oh wow it's going to
change my life and i did it through all
the struggles obviously that
are found in the industry and also that
difference
in terms of culture in terms of the
place in terms of people
it helped me to to grow and i managed to
navigate
the space i started aselina wines
in 2016. officially launched
in 2017 but the very first production
was in 2014
i was working for a winery and for about
13 years
working as a winemaker me starting
aselina it was
just growth progression to say what's
the next step
even though i knew from the beginning
when i was a student that at some point
i'm going to start my own business
and the reason the company was named as
lena was
because of my most amazing
strong woman my grandmother i named the
company after her
to honor her to pay tribute to her life
and even though she's late but i know
she's always with me when sometimes
i hit a wall or i find myself i need to
make a decision
sometimes i do ask myself what will she
have done she was one of those people
who
nothing was impossible there was always
a way there was always a way of making
something
for me i think that's the message it
also gives to everyone who want to do
something
nothing is impossible nothing is
impossible
we've got four different wines that we
we've made we've got two white wines and
two red wines
and at this moment we don't have our own
farm we don't have our own vineyards we
don't have our own
production facility but we are growing
to that and each and every wine that i
make it represents
the people behind it it represents the
love it represents
authenticity it represents um
courage and at the same time it's one of
that for me
that when you pour this wine in a class
where does it take you to
what do you imagine when you're having
that one in the class don't tell them
about the ph don't tell me about
just what does where does it take you it
must create that memory it must remind
you of your life it must remind you
of certain things that you grew up with
that's what happened whenever i make a
wine
i bought all this yesterday and this is
the very first time i'm opening this
this is where i always say this is the
the moment of truth
so when i was going to make the shadow
now that so what is it that i want to
make
i said i want one in the middle i made
decided to make a shadowing that is
partly wooded
from a warmer climate region and also
from the cold farming so i make
chardonnay from
stellenbosch and elgin i make them
separately
the elgin one is wooded the stellenbosch
is unwooded i leave them on the list
and then i blend it together after 10
months and so what comes out of that
is the life in the glass
oh the smell even like just in the glass
without even getting it in my mouth
i think what i like here as i smell this
wine
to pick up that those different flavors
a lot of citrus it's like there's a
there's a little bit of lime
it's just for me you are not gonna taste
lime if you've never eaten lime
so i might pick up something here and
you're gonna smell it and you
associate it with something else so
you're gonna pick up something that you
know it's gonna remind you of things
that
you know and things that you enjoy it it
gets on your palate it stays
it's it's not heavy it's it's there's a
crispiness but at the same time it's
rich
that balance for me it's
because there's so much going on in the
palette there it's just so much
the richness of the wine for me it's
just it's outstanding
the next one that we have is the
cabernet sauvignon again looking at the
labels of my wine
for me it was the key to make sure that
i connect
with my my background i connect with
where i come from and so i made sure
that the logo besides
naming my company after my grandmother
but also the logo represents that
and that is using a calabash
which is our traditional beer holder now
i'm linking the two
part of my life which is i'm in the wine
industry but
i still love drinking my traditional
beer
so i'm going to use the calabash when we
started selling our wines we started
with the international market
as a small company we didn't have the
infrastructure to make sure that the
wine gets to
the to the consumer to make sure that
the wine gets to the peop to the hands
of the people who are going to be
drinking it
while with the international market it's
more like you ship the wine
and then it's the importer on the other
side who actually does the whole
distribution i don't have to worry about
the end consumer
there's that bit of earthiness it's like
you know when you
walking outside it's hot and just a
little bit of drizzle
of rain and then you're like oh okay and
then that
smell just it excites me but at the same
time when you still go in
you pick up those different fruits the
black currants
pick up a little bit of deck of foods
and one of the reasons because my
cabinet
part of it is from the heldeberg and
part of it is from simmonsberg so
these two areas they bring this
complexity
into the class as we taste this wine i
think
as i said earlier soft tannins fruit up
front
and for me that's the key and one of the
things that
i brought this chardonnay and this
cabernet sauvignon the cab is not
heavy cabernet sauvignon so it means you
can have it slightly chilled and have it
summertime but it's a beautiful bold
wine
but it's not heavy it's got structure
it's rich
so that's what you like
[Music]
if you want to see our black excellence
video on why courage is the key to life
check it out right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there do not make any decisions based on
money
none it's the worst way to make a
decision there's no
substitute for becoming an expert and
being the best at your craft